[Music]
if we contrast of the speech of this
mind which is fully aware of its
confused state the speech of that simple
consciousness of the truth then the good
we find that in the face of the frank
and self-conscious eloquence of the
educated mind it can be no more than
taciturn four to the latter it can say
nothing that does not already know and
say if it gets beyond speaking in model
syllables it says therefore the same
thing that is said by the educated mind
but in doing so also commits the folly
of imagining that it is saying something
new and different
it's very words shameful ignoble are
already this folly for the others says
them about itself this land of mine
perverts in its speech all that is
unequivocal because what is self
identical it is only an abstraction but
in its actual existence is in its own
self a perversion the plain mind on the
other hand takes under its protection
the good and normal that is what retains
itself identity its utterance in the
only way here possible then is to say
that good does not lose its value
because it may be associated or mixed
with the bad for this is its condition
and necessity and in this fact lies the
wisdom of nature yet this plain mind
well that imagined it was contradicting
what was said has in doing so merely
condensed into a trivial form the
content of spirits utterance in making
the opposite of the noble and the good
into the condition and necessity all of
the noble and the good it thoughtlessly
supposes itself to be saying something
else then that which is called Noble and
good is in its essence the reverse of
itself or that conversely the bad is the
excellent
here in paragraph 523 and and moving
towards the end of this section about
culture and alienation and rather self
alienation in culture we're gonna see a
really interesting dynamic being noted
one that I think has a lot of
contemporary applications as well as you
know within the the dialectic of history
as Hegel is discussing it and probably
also in his own time as well and what
Hegel is going to contrast here are two
different consciousnesses both of which
are caught up with in this alienating
culture whose whose features we have now
uncovered at least in outline through
the the previous paragraphs in this
section we saw that the noble and
ignoble consciousness really can't be
completely distinguished from each other
we saw that good and bad there's this
interpol arity going on between them
that you know trent you might say
transmutes the one into the other the
word that that miller is using here is
either perversion or inversion for care
right
we might actually if we want to be a
little flippant with us say that they're
having intercourse with each other right
and then we also saw that state power
and wealth which now at this point have
almost like completely vanished from the
scene of the discourse except as the
objects of witty talk carried out on the
part of a certain consciousness those
also were subject to it as well and we
saw that there was a might call the
sophisticated consciousness Miller's
translation here is you know the mind
which is fully aware of its confused
state it's eloquent self conscious
eloquence but I think that we might use
the word sophisticated or nuanced in in
the present about this this sort of
consciousness and what it does is it
takes in you know not necessarily the
totality but at least enough of it
enough of that poison pill to know that
nothing is
simple as the words in the witty talk
describing it make it out to be
certainly not the the true the good and
the noble right that the as Hegel is
going to talk about a simple
consciousness this is the person who's
been left behind in the culture who
feels unmoored in it and and this isn't
just one single type of person this is
not you know somebody who's lacking in
intelligence or somebody who simply was
sheltered in their life this could
actually be the the you know form of the
the sophisticated consciousness who said
gee I've had enough of this we need
something we can rely on something
that's that's that's straightforward
that is good that's honest that's
another word that we saw crapping up in
this section so there is this
interesting conflict that is going on
here and Hegel is not actually
unsympathetic to these these demands or
these expectations but he thinks that
they're going to founder so let's see
how this happens he says if we contrast
the speech of this mind that is the the
witty repartee the the discussion that
ranges over everything kind of a mixed
medley the the speech of this mind which
is fully aware of its confused state if
we can trance with that the speech of
this that simple consciousness of the
true and the good simple I in fact you
know we might say straightforward it
only has one side right the simple
consciousness of the the true and the
good which is able then to associate the
true and the good with particular
objects or turns them into ideals that
are yet to be realized but we feel in
our heart
notice that I'm going to pause here for
a moment notice that what's going on
here is not something that is that is
totally new on the scene in the
dialectic of the phenomenology of spirit
where have we seen these sorts of
appeals before the law of the heart
right virtue in the way of the world
earlier in the the reason section
earlier perhaps in the spirit section in
certain parts we can go even further
back into the self consciousness section
and think about what happened in the
transition from the master-slave
dialectic then into stoicism scepticism
and the unhappy consciousness this is
similar in many respects to what Hegel
had labeled and was associating with the
historical school movement way of life
of stoicism there is a true there is a
good instead of saying that noble he's
the word rational there right and you
know counterpose to that coming out of
the very failure of that that state of
consciousness was what Hegel was calling
skepticism and skepticism wasn't just a
sort of standoffish you know if we want
to use Hume sort of a billiard hall you
know kind of kind of a game that you
play with yourself no it was aware of
the self contradiction of the culture
that it was living and out of the entire
world of the fact that the good the true
the rational couldn't be you know in a
simple way
associated with this or that that
everything was kind of mixed up together
that things were turning into their
opposites or revealing the opposites
within their very hearts that the good
was not wholly good that the rational
contained a seed of irrationality within
it and that consciousness itself was not
able to sort of stand off against this
as itself the true the good the rational
but was mixed in with this it could not
escape it so we're seeing here a
repetition but now in terms of language
now in terms of culture now in terms of
the orientation of the individual to
social forces such as you know state
power and wealth so coming back to the
text Hegel says that we find that in the
face of the Frank and self-conscious
eloquence of the educated mind the
educated mind the cultured the you know
you might say built up mine
which is you know building is building
on yourself he says it has a frankness
it has a self-conscious eloquence even
if it knows that it doesn't have the
solution everything it can at least say
well here's what the situation looks
like you know and if we want
contemporary examples pick any any any
issue in our modern culture and start
picking it apart and looking at it in a
careful way you know don't be the one
sided straightforward consciousness
about it be nuanced look at it in its in
its multiple senses and see that even
when good is being done there's also
some bad lurking in the background and
that good has to be done in response to
bad or the rational develops out of the
irrational and then opposes it and we
can go on and on and on with this what's
opposed to that so self-conscious
eloquence over here here's where it gets
really interesting and it's again
extreme a language this straightforward
consciousness the the simple
consciousness he says it can be no more
than taciturn and what is taciturn it
doesn't say all that much it shuts up a
lot of the time he says to the latter it
can say nothing it does not already know
and say when this is trying to speak to
this it can't tell it anything
fundamentally new and we have this
experiences it's quite interesting as
professors when we have indoctrinated
students from left and right you know
you know you might say foot soldiers in
the culture wars coming into our
classrooms and telling us about how it
is and we're like buddy
I knew that 20 years ago I already
thought that thought and I thought it
out further than you did and here's
where that thought actually leads to we
appear jaded to them they then become
taciturn they're like oh I guess I
should just shut up there's nothing else
to say so he says if it gets beyond
speaking in mono syllables it says the
same thing that is said to the educated
by the educated mind but it commits a
folly it commits a foolishness a to
height being being crazy and in some
respects of imagining that it's saying
something new and different now notice
what Hegel says after this he uses words
like shameful and ignoble and he says
that's already part of its folly this is
where we have people whether they're
young people or old people discovering a
cause discovering a key that unlocks the
story of the culture of the world or the
culture of the West or the culture of
the present moment and applying that in
a cookie cutter fashion to everything
that is you know these are the good
people these are the bad people because
they're part of this narrative and
there's they're part of this narrative
I'll use an example that I run across
quite frequently in philosophy the whole
world is Platon as' and Aristotelian so
we just got to figure out who lines up
where and which one is the good one
right so probably the Aristotelian
because they're they're more empirical
right well that's if you read crappy
histories of philosophy or histories of
ideas or even stuff that's not quite at
that level only by that would you say
that put that Aristotle is an empiricist
all right there are certainly empiricism
elements to Aristotle's philosophy but
there's there's far more than that and
then you know they start doing you know
pasting it onto things where do we put
the contemporary stoic sorry
are they Aristotelian czar Platon us now
the correct answer is
hey buddy they're neither they don't fit
into that nice you know checkerboard
that you want to place everything onto
but these people do it and why do they
do it you might say well it's a desire
for certainty based in you know whatever
psychological needs they have and there
that is correct in some cases in other
cases it's because there's an adventure
involved when you have a key like that
you know this happens to people when
they read Nietzsche for the first time
Wow
I understand the whole world is masters
and slaves and I'm going to be one of
those uber mentioned I'm not going to be
one of those herd morality people you
know and they start diagnosing it
everywhere you
I heard more immoralist you know then
everyone Lexi why what are you talking
about there's an adventure there's an
excitement that's involved in doing that
particularly when you hook up with a few
other people who talk the same language
as you and you get down you know into
those sorts of things and talk about it
over coffee or beer or whatever it is
that you're gonna you're gonna have but
it doesn't go anywhere
Hegel's say he says this is foolishness
he says that this latter mind perverts
in its speech all that is unequivocal
because what is self identical is only
an abstraction things that are self
identical tautologies are just
abstractions they don't really help us
out with anything and this is the the
problem with all of these you might say
pasteboard
you know poster session you know takes
on unreality he goes on and he says it's
actual in its actual existence it is in
its own self a perversion when we're
grasping realities as such particularly
when we're engaged with ideas and
persons or movements or events they're
always way more complicated that's the
well that's why the self-aware
consciousness is talking about things
the way that they are they would love if
things were simple but they aren't so we
go on a little bit further he says the
plain mind and here he's using this term
grata that's what's being translated as
plain you know when you when you have to
go straight the straight mind we might
say this is the straight this is the
crooked right or this is the straight
and this is the complex the plain mind
on the other hand takes under its
protection the good and the noble the
able what retains its self-identity in
its essence and its utterance in the
only way here possible what's the only
way here possible the good does not lose
its value because it may be associated
or mixed with the bad for this is its
condition and necessity so here's a
little bit of sophistication on this
part a little bit of advance we're going
to say alright I understand
the good isn't completely holy good but
at least we've got the good and that
little bit of evil that might be
associated with it or that you know a
little bit of egg nobility in the noble
is actually kind of you know enhancing
it and bringing it out Hegel says wow
that that's a nice thing to say but it's
really not going to work as a strategy
so he says this plain mind while it
imagined it was contradicting what was
said over here has been doing so merely
condensed into a trivial form the
content of spirits utter in spirit is on
this side and again this is where the
students come to us and they say I've
realized that this is the case and
you're like yeah sorry I know you think
that's an original thought and you think
that's really important that you have
like said something that encapsulated
all of the reality and you have made an
advance you're no longer just you know
doing good good good good good over and
over again but this is not something
really that new nor is it really that
complicated but good for you you're
you're getting there so Hegel goes on
and he says in making the opposite of
the noble and good into the condition
and necessity of the noble and good then
you need to sort of contrast you need a
sort of dynamic of these things you know
being in tension with each other it
thoughtlessly supposes itself to be
saying something else then what it is
called that then that whit what is
called Noble and good is in its essence
the reverse of itself or that conversely
the bad is the excellent it's still
trying to hold on to these and saying
things like well you can't have the good
without the bad or if we didn't have
evil in the world we wouldn't know that
good existed or you know ignoble people
allow the noble person to you know stand
out we don't say noble we say excellent
or we say flourishing or we say all
sorts of things like that we talk about
them as leaders right the leadership
literature is actually kind of full of
this sort of thing Hegel thinks that the
the weight of culture is really on this
side and notice
so I put self-aware consciousness of
culture it's not only aware of the the
nature of the world and what it's caught
in it's also aware although Hegel
doesn't spell this out at this point of
this dynamic between these two types of
consciousness here and it's not
necessarily happy about that any more
than the skeptic in the skepticism
section was happy about being caught in
the toils of that mental morass so where
will we go from here we have to look
ahead to the next several paragraphs
if the simple consciousness compensates
for this dull uninspired thought by the
actuality the excellent by inducing
an example of the latter either in the
form of a fictitious case or a true
story that's showing that it is no empty
name and actually exists the universal
actuality of the perverted action stands
opposed to the whole of the real world
in which the set example constitutes
something quite single and separate and
it's best
aamir sort of thing and to represent the
existence of the good and the noble as
an isolated anecdote whether fictitious
are true is the most disparaging thing
that can be said about it finally should
the plain mind demand the dissolution of
this whole world of perversion a cannot
demand of the individual that he removed
himself from it for even Diogenes in his
table is conditioned by it and to make
this demand and the individual is just
what is reckoned to be bad that is to
care for himself qua individual but if
the demand for this removal is directed
to the universal individuality it cannot
mean that reason should give up again
the spiritually developed consciousness
it is acquired should submerge the
widespread wealth of its moments again
in the simplicity of the natural heart
and relapse into the why of the
wilderness of the nearly animal
consciousness which is also called
nature or innocence on the contrary the
demand for this dissolution can only be
directed to the spirit of culture itself
in order that it return out of its
confusion to itself as spirit and win
for itself is still higher consciousness
paragraph 524 represents a very
important turning point in in this
dialectic and we're getting very close
to the end of the section what we'll
come back to that in just a moment but
what I want to say first is what's
happening is this this straight forward
or simple einfach consciousness is
attempting to do two little tricks you
might say or dodges the and it's doing
this in order to try to have what it is
that it's looking for the true the good
the rational the noble and we might say
you know reading into this by doing so
to have something that it can hold for
itself and recognize itself and Hegel is
not using the term honor King honor
Kenan here you know for recognition but
I think that's part of what what's
happening at this point now the both of
these are going to fail both of these
dodges or tricks or strategies if you
like are going to fail for good reasons
as we're gonna see in the paragraphs yet
to come but let's see where he actually
ends this this paragraph so he tells us
that there's a demand and this is part
of the second strategy to demand for a
kind of dissolution but not just a
dissolution a restoration can only be
directed he says to the spirit but not
just spirit Geist in general the spirit
of culture the spirit that's ruling the
world at this stage in order that it
return out of its confusion to itself as
spirit and win for itself a still higher
consciousness so the way forward is not
to try to go back and it's not to try to
simplify it's to go through the valley
to walk across the threshold to you know
make your way through the gauntlet to
take the blows and somehow come out on
the other side
the simple consciousness is trying to
avoid this at first and it's simply not
going to work but it's interesting
because you know as I mentioned we can
still see this dynamic playing itself
out in our culture in the present and
both of these are done just as much as
what was talking about in the previous
paragraph these sorts of resorts are
routinely engaged in so let's let's see
how Hegel describes it so we've got the
the simple consciousness and it creates
a kind of narrative it tells a kind of
story as Hegel says that the simple
consciousness is going to try to talk
about the actualities the reality of the
excellent and it's going to bring about
an example of the excellent so he says
either in the case the form of the
fictitious case like it writes a novel
or it makes a movie this is often a kind
of idealization you know so what we have
are people who are not happy with the
morass of culture that we live in tell a
story in which there's good guys and bad
guys and again this happens on both left
and right this happens with people who
think of themselves as very
sophisticated but are actually very
simple-minded about where our culture is
we have you know what you might call
culture warriors coming in from all
sides telling nice simple stories about
who wears the white hats and black hats
even if they reverse it so that you know
it's no longer white hats and black hats
but the black hats are the good guys and
the white hats are the bad guys or a
rainbow hat or wearing no we had it all
makes you a good person or wearing 15
different kinds of hats it's still still
the same white hat black hat story so
fictitious examples right are one case
or trying to find a true story which
then usually has to be simplified has to
have its edges shaved off has to have
some of the loose ends tied up so that
it will fit the nice narrative so he
says what is the aim here to show that
it is no empty name but actually exists
the true
exist the noble exist the good exists
then he says the Universal actuality of
the perverted action stands opposed to
the whole of the real world in which
this said example constitutes something
quite single and separate the year Hegel
uses this French term and it's best you
know this is translatable as species but
it really means like he says a mere sort
of thing you know when you say you know
and it's best the automobile it's not a
very good car you know it's best of watt
or you know it's best to shower
depending on high dialect you're talking
about right to make something into an
individual like that doesn't accomplish
what the person was trying to do because
the whole reason they created a
narrative is to say this one can stand
in place for many others but the
reduction then just to the individual
you know you look at oh I'm gonna read
this this story about this heroism and
bravery that's being displayed by you
know a infantrymen who never questions
what's going on over there or questions
just to the right extent in the war and
you think yourself well that's a really
great story and then while you're sort
of captivated by the imagery and all
that you're like yeah wow great of
anything how the hell is that supposed
to apply to me and this screwed-up world
of culture that I live in should I just
like withdraw into a fandom of this sort
of thing live in my little tiny you know
whatever cave it's going to be if I'm
gonna be out there in the world and I
try to communicate in these terms and I
say oh man I saw this movie and it was
about this guy or in this book and he
was so you know he was so heroic and
people are like that's all bs man don't
you understand that that's like you know
essentially propaganda and you're like
wait a second you know you're not can
you're not actually doing anything to
the world you're just sort of going into
your own little cubby hole if you do
that sort of thing so he
talks about this you know the the
perverted action the action that
actually shows that it's not just
entirely Noble entirely good so he says
to represent the existence of the good
and Noble as an isolate isolated
anecdote whether it's fictitious are
true is the most disparaging thing that
can be said about it isn't that an
interesting thing to say
the Hegel's not knocking random acts of
kindness or any sort of thing like that
or your post about the guy who saved the
puppy out of the floodwaters or anything
along those lines what he's knocking is
the idea that somehow this makes a
difference in the world of culture that
we live in that it isn't simply a
commodity thing to make you feel good
for a little bit of time as if well look
there's there's true nobility I mean
think about this you know we just had an
interesting example with this this
firefighter who everyone thought was so
so great and women were swooning because
he's so hot then it turns out you know
look in the social media
he's a neo-nazi and we can do this with
case after case after case after case
you think anybody is is you know truly
wonderful the way their bio says follow
them around for about a day or two and
and watch the varnish come off and
that's okay Hegel's not saying that you
know oh this just means we need to put
the varnish on even even better you're
saying look this is this is the world we
live in this is what culture is the way
through it is to go further somehow and
to come out on the other side so let's
talk about the second big dodge since
maybe the plane Matt mind demands the
dissolution of this whole world of
perversion now how is that gonna happen
we'll just tear it all down and start a
new people try this don't they these
attempts always fail because they bring
the world with them this goes back you
know this reminds me of something in
monastic literature John Cassian of whom
I'm a great fan and of whom actually st.
Benedict was such a great fan that he
recommended Benedict ins who were you
know really the most important monastic
in the early middle ages should read him
he talks about monks who think that by
going off to the desert and being in
isolation they're going to get over and
he's specifically talking about their
anger problems you know and he says
you're gonna bring the entire world with
you no matter where you go you're not
fleeing the world you are just bringing
it alongside you and if you're not going
to have any human beings to get mad at
you're going to get mad at your texts
you're going to get mad at your your pen
you're going to get mad at your sleeping
mat you're going to get mad at the wind
for blowing on you and we can say this
about everything else the person who
tries to say oh we're just gonna we're
gonna get away from all of it
no they bring civilization with them
certain aspects of it at least
so what can we do
Hegel talks about the simple
consciousness demands that the
individual remove himself from it and
then he says that doesn't work even
Diogenes in his tub Diogenes was you
know the second in the the cynic school
and ticinese founds it and AHA Janine's
is very famous for the sort of
self-imposed hardships that he would go
through
he lived in a barrel a tub he would
embrace statues he also broke with
social conventions and very funny and
interesting ways he probably would be a
stand-up comic today but probably a
dirty unwashed one if here around today
and of course he wouldn't he wouldn't
hold any job for very long the
individual still is formed by the
culture Diogenes is not as free as he
pretends to be as he's tweaking
everybody's noses
neither's the stand-up comic who you
know anything goes for them I mean to
begin it's never the case that anything
goes we make jokes about that you know
we these anything-goes types you do the
things that they are doing to other
people to them and suddenly oh oh it you
know that's not good or a great example
of this is the fact that everybody now
nowadays calls each other snowflakes
started out as a conservative versus
liberal thing but now it turns out that
that conservatives are just as touchy
and irritable and you know
unable to sustain themselves as
individuals rugged individuals as the
Liberals who are they're criticizing
they're all snowflakes right so if the
individual isn't going to work what if
we direct this to a universal
individuality this is interesting this
is demanding that the society itself
change and go back so he says
Hegel's he says this it cannot mean
reason should give up the spiritually
developed consciousness it is acquired
that was in advance we don't want to go
backwards he says it shouldn't submerge
the widespread wealth of its moments
into the simplicity of the natural heart
and relapsed into the wilderness with a
nearly animal consciousness which is
also called nature or innocence and this
was a very common motif in Hegel's time
this notion that if we could just get
back to the original people we wouldn't
all be such jerks to each other it's
culture that's corrupted us it's culture
that's made us you know so acquisitive
and exploitative
and filled us with resentment and you
know brought about all these unequal
power relations man if we could just
like find an island and you know live in
a Dilek life there Hegel's Hegel's one
of the first people would say you know
looking ahead hey you ever read that
book the Lord of the Flies
maybe islands aren't always the best
thing right Hegel says you know on the
contrary this is where we began the the
demand for this dissolution if you want
to try to bring about a new world you've
got to do it by addressing this demand
to spirit itself the spirit of culture
that somehow it transformed itself so I
can happen through the individual or the
some sort of universal withdrawing
itself it's not going to happen by
telling interesting stories it's going
to happen happen within the spirit of
culture itself
you